you guys may have seen this commercial
during the Super Bowl from McDonald's
they don't even want your money anymore
in McDonald's that's how much money they
have they want you to start paying with
selfies and calls to your mom and hugs
and other good stuff but don't take my
word for it let's take a look your
payment today tell me what you love
about your son I love says that she has
to dance right now
he paid with love and that's all we D
that's right so it's random locations
and they're gonna pick random people you
can pay with AI fives raising the roof
was there any other particular thing
that you liked in there that you can pay
with love I like that you call your mom
call your mom that's a good one
do you guys think this is cute or stupid
I'm kind of on the cute wagon for this I
give McDonald's a lot of [ __ ] around
here but I'm kind of bored like a little
silly gimmick well you would I like that
I actually when I watched it during the
Super Bowl I got a little bit cleanse
yeah um yeah and probably cuz I had
three glasses of wine but I I thought it
was a really good idea it's really
probably about selling more though
because if you go in there you know
you're like I could get this for free so
you're gonna get five happy meals
instead of just one happy meal right but
then if you lose then it's kind of a
lose-lose situation do you think that
they think that if you give if you pay
with the hug then you might be more
inclined to buy something else after to
possibly yeah but you know I'm hoping
that Pete Carroll went in there
afterwards and just binge ate McDonald's
and I really hope that he got some kind
of win because that poor man that was
the worst call in sports history
Jaqueline cute or stupid I mean it's
cute but I'm pretty cynical I think kind
of like you do maybe they did it hoping
to make more money wait you're saying
the business did something yeah well I
mean another does anything wrong with
that but they're playing in office we're
so charitable and generous but it's like
you under pay your employees you abused
the animals that you use in your food
and I'm an animal rights activist so I'm
always thinking about these types of
things right maybe they needed it for a
PR stunt maybe they're hoping to make
more money but I find it hard to believe
that they did this just out of the
goodness of their heart right so you
would have rather than like hugging the
cows before they slaughter them or
something or maybe just you know doing
it in a more humane way it would be nice
right that's probably not gonna happen
anytime soon I hope I hope it's a trend
though to that other companies kept on
cuz McDonald's is like a major leader
you know rather than just McDonald's
it's like McSorley's bar you know in New
York or Marc Jacobs or Michael Kors that
that would so you think that should just
be the new
the new way of paying for things should
be with affection selfies maybe a sexual
act how about just a high-five michael
kors here high five I'll do that dance
that other dude was doing you'll do that
for a bag or perfume I mean so if if
McDonald's really cared I'll go on your
simple right for a second the girls
really cared about happiness and the
welfare of their employees and their
customers they should be making better
food right but it is what it is it's
junk food you know you're on a road trip
and you know you are here mmm-hmm had a
long night you want those fries that are
covered with sugar apparently the fresh
sugar or God knows which they should be
making better food though right yeah I
think so I mean especially in America we
have a really bad you know health issue
going on and it's just kind of
perpetuating that but then again that's
a choice people go in knowingly you know
yeah doing anyways do you guys think
advertising works at all when I was
watching all the Super Bowl commercials
like I realized that half the time by
the end of the commercial I actually
forget what they were advertising for
you know they're always trying to be
funny which is fine but like that did
you watch a commercial and ever be like
alright I'm gonna go there and get that
product all I know is I woke up I was
covered in Doritos I mean I guess it
worked
yeah did you get insurance from that
very depressing what was that was that
State Farm or see I don't even know that
depressing insurance commercial with the
kid that was dead how I didn't say that
was yeah see I don't even remember there
was this really depressing commercial
about a dead kid nationwide someone
telling me nation oh hey there you go we
named three different they do they try
to pull out your heartstrings or do
something to make it memorable yeah I
want to go in there I'd like to go to
McDonald's just to see somebody get a
free meal and the person behind them
walk up to the register and be like 450
like why don't I get love yeah no one
likes you that's a good point if you're
behind the guy that gets to pay with
high you're gonna be pretty pissed yeah
good thing final thought on this what's
your favorite fast-food place you can
admit it the world god uh I mean
McDonald's man yeah you going through
the Worman grilled chicken no mayo
I never do that at two o'clock with no
mayo
I mean if I had to pick one I'd go Taco
Bell it's you know you can get
vegetarian really yeah I had to LA girls
here and either one of you said in and
out and either when he said your boat
leg I was thinking Chipotle but yeah I
didn't know if that was I guess I guess
it's a little it's a little higher have
you guys heard ablaze pizza
no this is a new one out here it's like
pizza that they make right in front of
you all fresh in five minutes is it a
drive-through it's uh you got to walk in
and it's a walk in Matador what it's a
restaurant it's okay anybody think about
that and maybe they'll let you pay with
hugs you could try it I'm gonna try that
for now on just walking into places
trying to buy things are paying with on
high-fives hand jobs whatever works
people